all right so a few moments ago i
mentioned how personally
i was affected by that nine-year-old boy
at the border the same age as my
youngest son
adam toledo was the same age as my
oldest son
i don't want to weigh in tonight on the
gun debate or the policing debate
i want to talk about the debate we are
not having but should be
about family and parenting and what kind
of monstrous society we've created where
a
13 year old boy is out on the streets of
chicago carrying a gun at 2 40 a.m
of course i'm not saying for a moment
that he deserved to die
but when i saw that unbearable police
video all i could think of
was my 13 year old asleep in our house
still thankfully retaining some of his
childhood innocence we work hard at that
in our family you have to work hard at
that these days raising a family
is hard it's the hardest thing anyone
does and the most important
but we barely talk about it as a matter
of public policy even though it's
foundational
to pretty much every other issue we do
talk about adam toledo's mother said
according to the new york times
that she had no idea that he was out the
night of the shooting and thought he was
safely in his room at the time
adam had been missing for several days
she said but had come home and
gone into the room that he shared with
his brother i'm sorry
but there is no conceivable excuse for a
parent to allow a 13 year old to be
wandering the streets in the middle of
the night with a gun
it's your job as a parent to not let
that happen but it is happening
in america today and less extreme but
much more widespread we see all around
us an erosion
of the boundaries children need none of
us is a perfect parent in a position to
lecture anyone else but we can and must
take this more seriously
as a society we can do much more
to help parents coach parents set
expectations for parents
if we really want to improve our society
that's the next revolution we need